one week from today we are releasing the
newest shirt in our artist series over
at microcosmos.store previously we've
made shirts that you can wear to show
your love for tardigrades and Hydra and
now it is time to show our abbreviation
for the algae that produces almost half
of the air that we breathe that's right
our little golden friend the diatom is
getting its own shirt designed by Josh
quick and it will be available for
pre-order next Monday February 6th at
microcosmos.store
foreign
[Music]
science is built on questions so let's
start today with a question what do you
think happens when you set off an
electrical spark in the microcosmos
maybe something like this little
fireworks show that James our master of
microscopes set off with a short circuit
perhaps your mind immediately jumps to
something destructive you got painful
shocks that tear things apart that fits
some of what's Happening Here the spark
James created was strong enough to chip
the glass slide it was strong enough to
break the bonds between hydrogen and
oxygen in water a process called
electrolysis we can't see those
individual atoms separating from each
other but we can see the end result
hydrogen and oxygen bubbles that build
and burst in front of our eyes or maybe
you think that electricity is more of a
productive Force something that creates
instead of breaks and that too fits some
of what we see here that same
electricity that broke apart water
molecules also created a world of
charged particles painting in other
worldly landscape in the process you may
also be a fan of the third option and
Chaos your mind replays images of frog
legs zapping to life or hair Defying
Gravity as electricity flows through
limbs the answer honestly might hem
shock you it is certainly not what I
would have expected so what happens when
you apply an electric field to the micro
Cosmos
order
[Music]
watch as this Whirlwind of ciliate
activity unworld winds itself abruptly
shifting to a uniform direction of
movement as if someone whipped out a
bull horn and yelled at them to get in
line of course there is no invisible
person with a bull horn there is just
James and a power supply that he used to
create an electric field across the
slide the movement that the ciliates
here are showing is a particular form of
motion called galvanotaxis though you
might also hear it called Electro taxes
many organisms exhibit galvanotaxis of
some kind even our own cells are capable
of it but today we're focusing on a
favorite group of organisms our fuzzy
single-celled eukaryotic friends the
ciliates though we should caveat that
not all silly it's behave this way
galvanotaxis has been particularly well
studied in paramecium and the ciliates
that we're watching today behave in a
similar way but still Affiliates are
vast and diverse and we've watched
ciliates of All Sorts change their
Motion in response to different types of
stimuli we've seen them move themselves
in the direction of chemical gradients a
form of motion called chemotaxis we've
also launched as some species either
seek out light like moths or shut it
like vampires those ciliates are showing
a form of light directed motion called
phototaxis galvano Texas is sort of like
these forms of motion and that the cells
are reacting to Something in the
environment around them or chemotaxis
and phototaxis those some things are
chemicals and light or galvanotaxis it's
a shift in the electric potential that
changes the flow of ions and particles
both around and within the organisms
but for ciliates galvanotaxis is also
fundamentally different from those two
other forms of motion chemotaxis and
phototaxis are both behaviors that give
ciliates some kind of benefit in the end
it can steer them towards food or light
for photosynthesis or away from threats
like predators and UV damage
galvanotaxis doesn't steer ciliates to
any obvious purpose or Advantage it is
just something that happens a function
of the way that ciliates themselves are
built not something that was selected
for by Evolution through natural
selection
[Music]
there is a whole sequence of events
based on electrochemistry that drive how
this happens it starts with an electric
field which creates a voltage gradient
across the microcosmos this gradient
interacts with the body of the ciliates
creating differences between the
interior and the exterior of the cell
that cause calcium and potassium ions to
flow across the membrane that is the
part scientists understand the part that
happens next is a bit more mysterious
that flow of ions changes the movement
of the ciliates Cilia those pair-like
structures that whip back and forth to
propel the organism around the
microcosmos at the front end of the cell
the flow of ions causes the Cilia to
beat more frequently a movement called
ciliary augmentation meanwhile at the
other end the flow of ions causes the
Cilia to beat more frequently as well
but in the opposite direction which is
called ciliary reversal
for the Cilia the opposing motions of
its cilia creates a torque that
ultimately directs the organism towards
the cathode the result as we see over
and over again in our samples is order
the changes in ciliary emotion that
drive this behavior is called the Ludlow
phenomenon named for the 19th century
scientist Carl ledloff who described its
occurrence in paramecium at the time he
thought the movement was simply a result
of electromagnetic interactions with the
Cilia but research since then has
revealed the underlying physiology of
the cell itself that makes this happen
and as we've said this is as far as we
can tell simply a function of how these
ciliates are built a consequence of
electrochemistry and electrophysiology
that combines into something that
happens with no purpose or advantage in
fact for some ciliates this leads to a
tragic end as they get too close to the
electrodes that inadvertently controlled
them
this does not mean that galvanotaxis is
functionless for James a careful
application of electricity to his
samples has become a valuable tool
helping him dig up microbes that are
hidden in his mud samples and our own
bodies even are a testament to the fact
that galvanotaxis can be an incredibly
powerful instructor it directs the
development of embryos repairs our
wounds and helps us grow our nerve cells
it is just one of the countless other
things that binds Our Lives to the
history of the microcosmos and the
invisible forces that cross all around
this Earth things that we humans have
found only by asking questions of the
universe and chasing down the many
possible answers until we fight
the next question
thank you for joining us as we explore
the Unseen World that surrounds us all
the names on the screen right now they
are our patrons on patreon they are
people who decide heck I want this thing
to exist I think that it's good I think
that it's lovely it makes me happy
brings me joy and also it does those
things for a lot of other people it
brings joy and knowledge to the world
and I think it should exist because it
can't exist without the support of those
people on the screen right now and if
you're interested in becoming one of
them you can go to patreon.com
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there is very likely a subscribe
button somewhere nearby